yo sí creo que esto puede Establecer un
precedente un precedente que las
legislaturas especialmente las
legislaturas republicanas han estado
tratando de diluir el voto negro
simplemente por ejemplo en un estado
donde la comunidad afroamericana podía
aspirar a ocupar dos o tres escaños en
el congreso lo que hacían es que ponían
a todos los afroamericanos solamente en
un Distrito
asegurándoles ese Distrito pero
reduciendo el la posibilidad de que
ganaran en el resto la Corte Suprema ha
dicho por una decisión de cinco contra
cuatro de que ese esa estructura es
inconstitucional de que no se puede
tratar de evitar que las comunidades
minoritarias ejerzan poder político
diluyendo su voto para el señor peñalver
se sabe que gran parte de las minorías
étnicas se inclinan hacia los demócratas
podría esto de alguna forma beneficiar a
los azules en las elecciones como las
presidenciales de 2024 claro y de
entrada ya
al decir que Alabama tiene que por lo
menos abrir la posibilidad de que haya
un segundo Distrito donde haya un
afroamericano como congresista eso puede
cambiar por completo el balance político
en el Capitolio y Abre las posibilidades
para que otros grupos minoritarios Pues
también puedan aspirar a ocupar cargos
en el congreso de los Estados Unidos es
una decisión extremadamente importante
la Corte Suprema tradicionalmente no le
gusta inmiscuirse en lo que es siempre
ha sido una una cuestión que la
legislaturas estatales decidan lo que
pase en sus estados pero la Corte
Suprema lo que ha dicho es es tal el
estar la forma en que se ha hecho esto
una forma tan tan abierta y con la
intención de evitar que esos grupos
minoritarios ocupen en el congreso que
la corte ha intervenido y esto yo creo
que puede ser simplemente un precedente
para que otros estados caigan en la
misma situación ahora
abrirle la posibilidad a otros grupos
minoritarios para que sean más
representados en el congreso bien
hablemos ahora de este giro que tomó el
presidente de la Corte Suprema John
Roberts hace 10 años por ejemplo votó en
contra de que los estados con
antecedentes de racismo necesitarán la
aprobación Federal para poder modificar
leyes electorales Pero hoy se unió junto
al juez conservador
junto a los jueces liberales a los tres
jueces liberales que están allí en esta
Corte Suprema podría decirse que la
presión ejercida por los movimientos
contra el racismo ha llegado incluso a
estas instancias han llegado a esta
instancias y el juez Robert se está
tratando de preservar su su rol ante la
historia él había perdido el control de
la Corte Suprema a un grupo de
republicanos conservadores nominados
principalmente
ellos por el expresidente Trump y lo que
él está tratando es de recuperar su
poder como presidente de la Corte
Suprema trataron de traer credibilidad a
la Corte Suprema a la gran sorpresa que
hoy ha sido el voto de cábala el voto de
cábala es extremadamente importante
porque es se ve como una figura que está
tratando de desarrollar su propia
personalidad hay veces en el
más liberal Y esa combinación de cábanos
con Roberts abre un nuevo una nueva
posibilidad para que la Corte Suprema no
se se aparte de esa vía tan conservadora
que había estado
dirigiéndose hasta ahora